russian artists and sports figures are
being asked to condemn the invasion of
ukraine or risk being banned from
performing in the west so should they be
forced to take a political position this
is inside story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm hasam
seeker across the western world russian
artists musicians filmmakers and
athletes are being excluded from events
and competitions they are under growing
pressure to denounce the actions of
russian president vladimir putin that's
despite laws to protect the freedom of
expression for all people living and
working in europe and north america
the munich philharmonic has sacked its
star conductor and putin supporter
valerie gergiev
the soprana
anna netrebka had to withdraw from
several events including new york's
metropolitan opera she wrote on
instagram opposing the war only to
delete the post but she stayed silent on
president putin
and in tennis the british sports
minister has warned russian tennis
players especially world number two
daniel medvedev they may be barred from
wimbledon unless they denounce vladimir
putin
and talking about the british government
is like i said
i think
we should
show a great example that tennis is
out should be outside of politic
and not tennis in general sport because
we are athletes
we want to compete we were
sacrificing so many things sport should
be outside of the
politic because everyone
say this
but
in the end
looks like still it's not happening so
that's why i hope
that we in sport they will show that
there is no politics and we will be a
good example to
have a like a huge step forward
but some cultural figures say artists
should take a clear political stance on
the war in ukraine russian-born german
pianist and political activist igor
levitt wrote on instagram being a
musician does not free you from being a
citizen from taking responsibility and
that bringing up music as an excuse to
remain vague is an insult to art
so let's talk more about this now with
our panel in doha we have natalia
pellevin a british russian playwright
political activist and blogger in moscow
alexis yarashevsky a russian sports
reporter
based in moscow also in doha daniel
reich visiting associate professor at
georgetown university qatar his research
focuses on sports policy and politics uh
welcome to all of you uh natalya if i
could start with you and if you could
talk about the the circumstances of how
you you came to uh uh dolha and um
your position on on
people going after uh russian artists
and and and sports uh uh people over
this
well i've been uh in opposition to putin
for a very long time in fact i was
raised abroad but i came back to russia
in 2012
precisely to
work against putin against his regime
which i
felt and and knew as we all did in the
opposition
will come to something like this
something horrific
um
and um and since then we we've been um
brutally fighting with not much results
unfortunately i've had the criminal
cases against me i was prosecuted etc by
by those in power for for my opposition
stance um
but i've kept myself in russia fighting
for all those years i haven't left up
until this point when i've realized that
not only am i in danger because i'm
vocal about my opposition to the war in
ukraine but my child is in danger and
that's when i packed our bags and we
went to doha which is where we are now
um for for a brief period of time
hopefully hopefully this will be over
the war will be over soon and then i
hope to go back to russia and continue
doing what i was doing but
with regards to all the public people um
including sportsmen and people in the
arts
and uh and and their stance on uh on on
the war well i believe anyone who is
with a public life who has many many
followers needs to take a very firm
stance
and this stance needs to be
in line with what the civilized world
has already expressed and the civilized
world has condemned this horrific war
so this is what those people who want to
work and and compete
uh and uh and and it should be global
um they need to take a very firm stance
whether it's a tennis player medvedev
whereas whether it's near trebco the
opera singer they need to they need to
do this because this is important to not
only be not only because a civilized
world otherwise should not really accept
them uh in the future but also because
this is a moral thing to do i believe
we're in a position where it's very much
black and white i'm very much against
black and white generally speaking but
we're in an unprecedented and horrific
uh
point in our in our life in our
civilized life
on this planet we haven't faced anything
of this magnitude since the world war ii
so this is time to be
on the right side on the side of the
good
and and those people
famous people wealthy people
worldly people if they are not prepared
to maybe sacrifice a couple of contracts
with gasprom
to to be on the right side then they
shouldn't be part of the civilized world
they shouldn't be allowed to compete
globally they shouldn't be they should
be with the with the normal people and
working with the normal people and
working for the normal people for the
time being at the very least and i think
in honesty i think there will be
probably blacklist that anyone who
doesn't want to comply with uh with
what's you know what is the right thing
to do really at the moment i think they
will be blacklisted uh for a very long
time and i think there should be because
this really is a breaking point okay for
all of us
aleksi arashevsky you were shaking your
head earlier is it right to punish
athletes and artists over this
well of course not i mean i agree with
the general notion that uh you know
stances should be heard and people
should
express their opinions on what's going
on right now in ukraine uh well
obviously it's a free world then we have
to express our
um you know uh approval or disapproval
of that but uh let's be real about it i
think it's a bit naive to think that if
daniel medvedev or alexander avechkin or
any other prominent russian athlete or
global sporting celebrity a cultural
celebrity says no to war get out of
ukraine this will not stop anyway we've
seen it time and time again uh we have
an example of uh a famous russian
footballer fedor smalloff who was among
the few big name athletes here in russia
saying uh his disapproval of what was
going on in ukraine did that stop the
bombs falling did that stop the military
conflict of course not uh the
one thing that people have to understand
is that uh we have obviously elite
athletes like alexander avishkin in the
nhl who did say his no to what's going
on in ukraine but did not take down the
avatar on instagram where he is with uh
the russian president obviously getting
a lot of abuse for that but he continues
playing he continues scoring goals and
trust me the washington capitals fans
absolutely love what aveskin is doing on
the field of play um but on the other
hand we have um sportsmen and athletes
from different types of sports here in
russia who are being castigated from the
world sporting community for no reason
whatsoever they've never supported the
military conflict in ukraine they've
never voted for it they've never vocally
supported it and yet they are being cast
aside by um you know you know the likes
of thomas bach the president of the ioc
who basically started this whole process
of castigating russian athletes and you
know in the case of uh daniel medvedev
the aforementioned tennis player in the
case of alexander adeskin and many other
footballers for instance uh russian
footballers across the planet they are
very wealthy people they are
multi-millionaires in many cases but
let's talk for instance about
paralympic athletes who were kicked out
from beijing a day before paralympic
games were supposed to start let's talk
about skiers let's talk about
bi-athletes let's talk about gymnasts
and all the other people who only have
one means to survive it's doing sport
here they were already cast out from the
international sporting family and if
they speak out here in russia and trust
me you you and you know what i'm talking
about they will have problems here as
well so they basically have nowhere else
to go um we have to think about these
people as well of course saying you're
no or yes to what's going on in ukraine
is a vital thing but i think in the case
of athletes
this is just a little bit too risky for
them and their livelihoods in the future
uh daniel wright what what's your uh
what's your take on this and and for
those who
uh say sports and and
um politics in particular shouldn't
shouldn't go together uh
that's the history of that shows that
this is not uncharted territory is it
yeah of course
but
in general when it comes to sporting
boycotts the era of sporting boycotts
has ended we had a lot of boycotts in
the 1970s and 80s and 1976 african
countries were boycotting the montreal
olympics
um to protest apartheid in south africa
1980 uh the us and other western states
boycotted the moscow olympics and
protest of the soviet invasion of
afghanistan 84 in los angeles there was
some retaliation by east european states
but since the end of the cold war at
every single olympic games the number of
participating countries has increased
so we did not see boycotts anymore
uh in the 90s and forthcoming years
there have been a couple of individual
boycotts by arab athletes on israeli
athletes but in general uh the era of
boycott has ended so this is a very
special situation now
it's maybe a bit like 1948 when uh
germany and japan were not allowed to
participate in the summer olympic games
as a punishment for the second world war
and this time
russian athletes and teams are excluded
to prevent the third world war natalia
pellevin if i could turn back to you on
this um you know alexi made the point
there uh that this is this is punishing
uh a lot of athletes particularly in
russia who who um uh don't make a huge
salary uh and they're being caught up in
this through no choice um of their own i
mean you know foreign-based athletes who
who have the the the notoriety and and
and and uh
are able to are in a position to to
speak out if they want but others are
being punished unnecessarily honestly
everyone is being punished necessarily
at this point
if if those people in the sports they
still vote right i mean they don't only
just do sports they have the right to go
and vote if all those years they voted
for putin
this is their punishment if they just
kept silent and did nothing this is
their punishment i'm very sorry but
that's just how it is
anyone who didn't stand up in time to
this dictator who led us to this point
when we're in the middle of a horrible
unjust completely unnecessary bloody war
is punishable
along with putin this is not just putin
at this point come on people we have to
realize it it's the russian people who
allowed him to get to this point
or punish should be punished as well not
just athletes general russian public
which is being punished with the
sanctions economic century but that's
not what we're talking about today but
going back to the famous atlas because
medvedev was mentioned on a few
occasions i firmly believe that the
global sports community
should not accept in its ranks
athletes who don't have the guts and the
decency to stand up against the bloody
war that russia is leading in ukraine
they just should not be accepted period
alexia i know you want to respond to
some of that and i also want to ask you
i'm sure you're aware of the the what
happened a couple of days ago with the
um
uh the uh russian artistic gymnast ivan
kuliak uh here in doha he displayed the
uh the zed sign on his vest which is
as you know seen as a symbol of support
of russia's actions uh in ukraine uh he
was on the medal podium um and what what
offended a lot of people particularly
the international gymnastics federation
was was not just that but the fact that
he was standing next to
the ukrainian athlete who won the gold
medal so they are
opening up an investigation into that
are they right to do that
well to be honest with you i'm not a big
fan of political statements in the field
of play i've been long taught that sport
and politics are two different beasts
and they should not be in the same part
but even judging by what natalia was
saying there you know that athletes
should be
you know not let in to participate in
the international competitions uh simply
on the basis of the fact that they
belong to russia that they are russian
and uh
whether they have voted for putin or not
we don't know that uh i think it's it's
just preposterous that we have come to
this stage where uh culture sports and
things which are so distant away from
politics are now being completely uh
politicized uh and you know in in the
case of this gymnast i don't approve of
what he did and i do believe that he
should be punished for that uh but at
the same time let's remember
multiple cases when um uh athletes
you know expressed their opinions in the
field of play and they were punished as
well so if that is the principle it is
applied equally to every single athlete
and um there was also a case during the
beijing olympics when a ukrainian
athlete um brandished a no-war slogan he
wasn't really punished but there was um
you know there were the war talks
between him and the representatives of
the ioc that he shouldn't be doing that
even though he wasn't actually
supporting anything he was uh to the
country saying that there shouldn't be a
war happening in ukraine uh this is a
very dark territory but um i'll give you
another example we're talking about
russian athletes here uh who may or may
not be allowed to participate in
international competitions i mean i
respect
you know different opinions on that
matter but i'll give you a different
example there is a big football star in
russia who is georgian his name is
cliche he plays for rubin kazan and um
the latest information that is being
widely speculated now in the russian
sports media is that his family is
receiving death threats right now that
if he continues playing in russia uh the
family will suffer consequences so
basically someone i don't know whether
that's someone english speaking or
ukrainian speaking doesn't really matter
for that point they're hounding out a
player and sending death threats to his
family so that he leaves russia and goes
somewhere else and now there's an
international break in football going on
so he left russia he may not be coming
back how is that all right can someone
explain to me is is this part of part of
what is this part of uh the sports
without politics kind of thing see it's
just crossing all the boundaries and i
don't think to be honest that athletes
should be paying the price for what
governments do because we don't remember
any us athletes or uk athletes or any
other athletes being banned by
international sporting organizations
when these countries were engaged in
military conflicts all over the world
and now it's the case with russians and
i think it's unjust unfair and it's
killing russian sport effectively just
like it's pretty much been happening
over the last uh four or five years due
to you know different reasons let's
let's put some of that back to natalia
then is is is there a line that's being
crossed here when you go after not just
certain athletes but their families as
well
well i feel very bad for anyone who gets
death threats and threats in general
i've been getting threats uh for the
past 10 years from pro-putin uh
pro-kremlin or around kremlin movements
and things uh so i know what that's that
is about um so i feel bad about that but
there's always an extreme reaction to to
those to those things obviously i i
think that people who are you know
taking it to that to that level uh it's
very stupid completely unasked for it
and it shouldn't be happening however i
still do believe that if you um if
you're a russian athlete and unless you
vocally especially if you're famous if
you're not famous then you don't have
many followers then maybe you know
it doesn't make much of a difference but
you as some of those people are there
some of those assets are very famous
they have lots of followers on social
media if they don't don't take a firm
stance because they
they're
afraid of consequences within their
russian sort of whatever
life and then and and workplace and
whoever they work for
then that's just um
that's a sure sign to me that the the
they should be bad from from the rest of
the
global um athlete community because if
you don't have the guts you don't have
the moral stance in you to react to
something as horrific as what we see
going on in ukraine then we don't want
to deal with your period is what i feel
daniel wright do boycotts of whether
they're of of athletes or artists or any
anyone in in culture do they ultimately
make a difference and by making a
difference i mean
do they force uh the the the person or
the regime that's being targeted to to
change their position to change their
policy
it depends i mean uh the boycott on
apartheid south africa was certainly
successful and south africa was for a
long period of time excluded from
international sports and when we started
the end of apartheid this sporting
boycott might have been one reason
uh israel was boycotted at the asian
games in the 60s and 70s and was then
expelled from asian sporting federations
and is now a member of european sport so
this has been also
successful
but uh overall
uh the architecture of international
sports is that
athletes and countries compete with each
other regardless of different ideologies
politics religions and so on
so this should be like really an
exception uh to boycott because
otherwise the international sporting
system would not function i can just
share something from discussions with my
students in my classes so they have been
critical and said they are double
standards because the many western
countries would accept the treatment of
the palestinian people and not boycott
israel why he is now a different action
in the case of russia and ukraine this
is true i share this criticism
but i think wrong acting in one case
doesn't justify to act wrongly in
another case and we are really in a very
critical situation given sense since
russia has um
nuclear weapons so there's really the
risk of like a global conflict so i
think while i'm in general against
sporting boycotts i think in exceptional
circumstances like this one it's
justified
uh what's your view on that then alexi
sometimes things like this are justified
and uh culture and and sport in general
uh as unfortunate as it is will become a
kind of collateral damage uh to to to
actions uh such as uh
russia's actions in ukraine
listen let's not uh i won't be very
blunt about it i don't support what's
going on in uh ukraine i lived in
ukraine i know this country very well
and i uh and i've been in shock since
day one there's no justification to me
as to what's happening there it cannot
be um justified in any way uh but at the
same time there's another side to the
story that uh almost i feel like uh i am
russian and i'm evil by default and that
is not true because if you look at how
much this country has given to the world
culturally wise sports wise
i just came back from beijing olympics i
spoke to numerous athletes from all over
the world from australia to norway and
you know we already had a situation in
beijing when everyone started talking
about russia again not for a good reason
not for a bad reason but for another
doping scandal or doping allegations
against a nice figure skater and i spoke
to many athletes and they said listen if
they kick you out from sports uh this
will be a big loss to us because
russians are among the strongest
athletes to compete against russians are
um proving to be a very hard competition
for us so if you're just gone from the
face of the sporting earth uh we'll just
win all medals and it wouldn't only be
fun for us it's not going to be as
competitive as it was
we never tend to think about that and
talk about that in the context of what's
going on in ukraine uh especially if you
look at what's happening uh what's been
happening in the past uh
with military countries all over the
world and very few countries were
actually punished for it if you remember
yugoslavia of course they were kicked
out from the footballing world cup uh
for uh their onslaught which was
happening there but other than that
there are just very few examples of the
same thing happening to
russia right now indeed the world is
coming together uh criticizing russia's
actions in ukraine but uh the
long-lasting effect of uh you know it
has on culture and sports will be will
be felt and the shops will be re
reverberating across the planet uh again
simply because russia has a big place in
sports and culture worldwide and you
know what saddens me the most for this
matter is that uh things like sports and
culture they should be uniting people
and in this case uh they're only like
putting people even further apart
especially in the case when um new
sanctions are being used and i can tell
you that the reaction here in russia is
being very negative about that it adds
to the notion that um you know to those
who are supporting the actions in
ukraine they're saying okay they're
sanctioning our athletes
they're kicking out our musicians and
things like that it makes people even
more angry so what good does it do for
the
resolution of this matter i have no idea
let's put this back to natalya uh
briefly the point that alexi makes there
i mean our i mean sports and arts have
often acted as a bridge between cultures
and nations so by punishing the
practitioners of those things don't
don't you risk burning bridges
well bridges have been burned by putin
there's really not much to repair at the
moment and putin is the one who divides
everybody putin is the is the one who is
uh was making this world a much worse
place by his actions so it's as
unfortunate as it is as uh as has been
mentioned that some of those uh athletes
who don't make too much money who are
not world famous athletes um are put in
a position when they can't compete well
it's unfortunate but that is the price
you pay for competing for the country
that is led by a bloody dictator that is
just how it is okay uh and
that's that's the term we used for a
long time when it wasn't completely
justified now unfortunately it is he is
a bloody dictator
so everybody else collateral damage in
this situation on that we are going to
have to leave it thank you very much to
all three of you natalia pelleven alexis
yaroshevsky and daniel reich thanks very
much for being on inside story
and thank you as always for watching
remember you can see the program again
anytime just go to our website at
jazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle there is at aj
inside story for me hasm seeker and the
whole team here bye for now